culture may feel exclusively human but
it's been observed in all types of
animals
from chimpanzees to birds but what about
the humble invertebrate do fruit flies
have culture researchers tried to find
out if fruit flies might have their own
cultural assets to pass down through the
generations by looking at mating
preferences they set up five rules to
define whether a behavior was learned
and cultural first the female fly must
learn their mate selection preference
from watching other female flies choose
a mate for example when an observer
female watched a second female select a
green male to copulate with the observer
females overwhelmingly chose a green
male when faced with their own mate
selection second the learned behavior
must be passed from older to younger
flies the observer female selected a
green male regardless of whether they
saw copulating females that were older
or a similar age third the mating
preference must persist after showing a
female fly a green meal copulating every
15 to 30 minutes several times the
observer female predominantly chose the
green male even after 24 hours passed
since fruit flies only live for about 40
days 24 hours is a significant slice of
their life fourth the copying is based
on a specific trait even when faced with
a green male that had another prominent
feature like white eyes or curly wings
the observer female still usually
preferred them over pink males
lastly the mating preference has to have
a repair mechanism
in all the experiments 80% or less of
flies learned a mate preference from
observation without a mechanism to
correct for the 20% of flies that didn't
learn the mate preference should
theoretically drop down to 51% by the
third generation however researchers
found that learned behaviors persisted
much longer during the experiment down
to the eighth generation researchers
tested to see whether showing several
demonstrations of copulation would lead
to a higher percentage of learned mate
preference when observer females saw
equal proportions of demonstrator
females copulating with green and pink
males the observer females had no mate
preference in contrast if all the
demonstrator females were copulating
with green males a hundred percent of
observer females went with the majority
and chose a green mate this exaggerated
tendency in the Flies to copy the
majority demonstrates the repair
mechanism the scientists think their
work could shed some light on how social
pressures produce local traditions these
in turn might drive evolution as they
spread in our pasts down in vast nations
of humans or tiny fly colonies and fruit
books